-Thanks for remembering!
-That's exactly -- Welcome.
-I'm still hurting
over that Password loss.
-[ Laughing ]
Oh, my gosh. I got to say,
thank you so much
for coming back to my show.
I appreciate it.
-Well, let me just say something
to you, truthfully,
and just before you jump into
all your prepared notes,
I was going to say that, really,
of all the NBC late night shows
currently on the air,
this is in my top two.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. And, you know, I would
do the show way more often
but, you know...pride.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey.
-No, seriously, seriously,
I just -- Seriously,
I just want to say
that you have been here
every night
during this incredible crisis.
You've been doing great work,
hilariously funny,
and it's very comforting
to have you, so thank you.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-Okay, now do me.
[ Laughter ]
-This the way it works?
Steve Martin,
I think you are a genius.
-Oh, I wasn't expecting that.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Wow.
-Hey, when did you remove
your Robert E. Lee statue?
Backstage, it was
such a tradition to see that.
-Yeah, yeah, and I moved it.
[ Laughs ]
Yeah, it must have
thrown you off backstage.
But, well,
I've got to be honest,
you guys both look fantastic.
-Oh, come on.
-Thank you. Thank you.
The pandemic is a challenge.
But I'll tell you one thing.
It was great to go around
the house for a year and a half
wearing no bra.
[ Laughter ]
And I let my hair go gray,
and I'm going to keep it.
-Oh, wow.
-You look fantastic, by the way.
You never -- You really --
Is it the horse deworming
medication you're taking?
[ Laughter ]
-I want to talk about
"Only Murders in the Building."
This is the most-watched comedy
premiere in the history of Hulu.
It's a major hit.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're great in it.
I'll tell you who's fantastic,
Selena Gomez.
-Unbelievable.
-Selena Gomez is fantastic.
-Hello. I'm also in it.
Steve's in it -- Let's go back.
Steve's great. Selena's great.
-Yeah, no -- Yeah.
-She is fantastic.
She came in our trailer
for the first time,
and she said, "Gee,
it smells like Grandma's house."
-Aww, that's sweet, you know?
-Yeah.
-No, she's an amazing actress.
And this is how I know
she's a great actress --
'cause when she met us,
she acted like she knew us.
-Aww.
[ Laughter ]
-The nice thing about Selena...
-What?
-She lays out our pills
for us in the morning.
-I mean, this is why
I can feel the chemistry.
Now, I'm about to show
everyone a clip.
Can you tell us what we're about
to see here?
-Yeah, well, we chose this clip
because you're in it.
You did us a favor.
Tina Fey is in it.
Nathan Lane is in it.
Marty and I are in it.
-Sting is in it.
-Well -- What?
-Sting.
-He's mentioned.
-Yes.
-He's not in the clip.
-Oh, no, sorry.
-Yeah, yeah, that's okay.
I think I can do this.
I can handle it.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I think --
-Yeah.
-Anybody else you want
to be in the clip?
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, Springsteen's in it!
-Beyoncé's in it.
-Oh, she's so good.
-Marlon Brando, and he's dead.
-Marlon Brando's in it.
He's dead, and he's still in it.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm going to stop now.
-Maybe we should just
show the clip.
-Or, yeah.
-Let it speak for itself.
-Yep. Well, it's your show.
[ Laughter ]
Let's take a look at
"Only Murders in the Building."
Take a look.
-The title of their podcast is
"Dimas Chicken Wraps Presents:
Only Murders in the Building."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I do love
Dimas Chicken Wraps.
[ TV shuts off ]
-Teddy, do you understand
how huge Fallon is in Greece?
[ Audience laughing ]
Do you know what my cousins
back on Nisyros are going to do
when they see this?
They're going to [bleep]
themselves, Oli!
They're going to squat
right down on their goat fields
and [bleep] themselves in envy!
[ Laughs ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-That's fantastic!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There's no one funnier
and no one more perfect
in everything he does
than Nathan Lane.
-Nathan Lane was spectacular --
And you were, too.
But Nathan Lane
is a professional and --
[ Laughter ]
-What does that mean?
-Oh, it --
-It was a stretch for Jimmy.
He was playing a talk show host.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to congratulate you
again on this.
It's a big, giant hit on Hulu.
Check it out.
"Only Murders in the Building."
Before you guys go,
I would just like to --
-Oh, we're going?
[ Laughter ]
-You don't have to.
-I get that a lot at parties.
[ Laughter ]
-"Hey, before you go."
-"Before you go."
-You go, "I just got here."
Yeah.
I wanted to see
if you wanted to say something
about our friend Norm Macdonald
who passed away.
-Oh, my God.
-Funny.
-Yeah.
-There was no one funnier.
Brilliant Canadian.
-You know, we do --
In our show,
we do a tribute to comedians.
I'm serious about this.
And we name different comedians,
like Bob Newhart and people.
And we do a tribute
to Norm Macdonald,
and we use one of his lines.
We say --
And this is one of his lines --
He said,
"There's only two categories
of cliff diving --
grand champion
and stuff on a rock."
[ Laughter ]
-But I really think
that in comedy, particularly,
the originals
stand out the most,
and they stay with us
long after they're gone.
And there was no one more
original than Norm Macdonald.
There was no one
who did his style.
There was no one who
had his rhythms.
He was remarkable
and so kind and funny.
-Yeah, I just figured
I'd get your thoughts.
Thank you so much
for being here.
You guys are the greatest.
Steve Martin, Martin Short.
"Only Murders in the Building"
on Hulu.